let's talk about startup schools
specifically y combinator
i've personally co-founded two separate
startups that have gone through y
combinator
and today i'm going to tell you
everything that you need to know about
the program
including how to get in but don't worry
if you aren't sure about my credentials
i'm going to pull plenty of quotes
directly from current and former y
combinator partners
and back everything up with data and
sources so you know it's accurate
i'm john coogan and this is everything
you need to know about y combinator
whether you call them startup schools
incubators or accelerators
these programs are a great opportunity
to grow your business
especially if you're a first-time
entrepreneur and still aren't exactly
sure of how silicon valley really works
there are lots of accelerated programs
around these days and they're all a
little different
for this video i'm going to focus on yc
for two main reasons
first it's what i know both of my
startups soylent and lucy have been
through the program
and i've never been a part of another
accelerator second
yc is by far the biggest and most
successful program out there they've
launched over 2
000 companies created over 60 000 jobs
and generated over 300 billion dollars
in market capitalization
that's incredible performance for any
investor but what makes yc so unique
is their speed and scale instead of
networking to meet founders
putting them through a series of pitch
meetings and requiring lengthy slide
decks
and detailed financial plans yc has a
standard application on their website
that anyone can fill out
and they decide who they fund based on a
10 minute interview
common questions about y combinator
generally fall into a few buckets
what's yc like should i apply
what does a good application look like
and how should i prepare for the
interview
i'm going to cover all of these but one
at a time let's start with what the
program entails
once you're accepted yc will invest 125
in return for seven percent of your
company to help you get started
then you participate in a three-month
program where you meet with other
companies
and attend regular dinners with guest
speakers the program feels extremely
short and it can fly by quickly
but it's an extremely competitive and
intense environment that will really
motivate you to build the best possible
company
yc ends with a demo day where you
present your company to investors
and usually try and raise more money for
the company to some people
that sounds amazing to others it might
sound underwhelming
the value of yc is a bit intangible but
i've never
met a successful founder who didn't
absolutely love their yc experience and
credit their early growth to the program
going through yc used to mean moving to
mountain view california
or at least the bay area but since the
pandemic hit last year yc has been
entirely remote
moving to silicon valley was a really
cool part of the experience
since you felt immersed in the startup
culture as soon as you got there
now you may be thinking that moving to
silicon valley feels super glamorous
and you'll be hanging out in amazing
places like the google campus
but usually you'll be in a cheap hacker
house instead
that's what happened to me with my first
company we were on a really tight budget
so we rented a cheap place in sunnyvale
about 30 minutes away from mountain view
and camped out there for the duration of
the program
if you're interested in taking your
startup seriously i definitely recommend
applying to y combinator
but it's common for entrepreneurs to not
be sure about when the ideal time is to
apply
but the good news is that there really
is no wrong time to apply
if your company is extremely early in
development you just need to listen to
what the head of admissions at yc
dalton caldwell says on the topic there
is no such thing as too early
sometimes in the extreme case people
have changed their idea between when
they get invited to interviews and when
they get to the interview we also fund
people that end up pivoting mid-batch
that means they've been working on their
startup like a negative number of days
that is clearly not too early also and
so again there's there's a lot of ideas
around there
that like the right way to apply to oic
is to wait until you have a certain
amount of stuff
any kind of roadblock you put for
yourself that you're too early i would
argue is your own
self-constrained roadblock not something
that's coming from us sometimes
companies think that they are too far
along for yc
but there are plenty of great companies
that have joined yc after raising money
hiring employees launching products or
starting to generate revenue
there is one case where you shouldn't
apply to yc though
and that's if you don't plan on growing
your company significantly
yc doesn't fund lifestyle businesses or
side projects
and those types of projects generally
shouldn't raise venture capital at all
side projects and lifestyle businesses
can be great experiences
but they just aren't what yc looks for
in companies that they fund
there are really only two things you
need in order to get into yc
a team and an idea current yc partner
jared freeman explained these
requirements really well
the first ingredient is you need your
founding team
that means you need the right set of
people
to work on your idea and the second
ingredient
is you need an idea that that team is
excited to work on
those are actually the only two
ingredients you need to have a
successful yc application
a lot of people think that you need a
bunch of traction
or a certain amount of revenue or
something like that but it's just not
true
anywhere from a quarter to a half of the
companies that yc funds
every batch are companies with just
those two things
just an idea and a founding team so if
that describes you
the next step is just to fill out the
application it's a very simple form
and you honestly shouldn't spend too
much time on it just keep your answers
concise and honest
avoid jargon and explain your plans
exactly as they stand
right now it's okay not to know
everything about the future
no one does a big part of the
entrepreneurial process
is adapting to change and growing as a
person and leader as your company grows
instead of spending days trying to craft
the perfect answer to every question
spend that time actually building your
startup the answers to the questions
will
come naturally at that point dawn
caldwell made a great point about the
importance of
actually starting to build your idea
before you raise money
at techcrunch disrupt the tech press is
so fundraising focused
the naive assumption about the way you
started startup is you first create a
pitch
deck and then you go network of
investors and then like the other part
about building a product what have you
as later and so that's certainly
something we look for in founders is
folks that don't put the cart before the
horse a lot of people think that they
should try and network their way into yc
or create some elaborate pitch for their
company in order to draw attention
but that kind of stuff actually works
against you try and put yourself in the
position of an investor or yc partner
imagine you're living in an apartment
building and two things keep happening
every day someone pounds on your door to
tell you about their great startup
and then every night you look out your
window and see someone burning the
midnight oil coding in the apartment
across from yours
the aggressive startup keeps pounding on
your door telling you how great their
idea is
but you see no evidence of this sure
they have determination
but you can't tell if they've actually
built anything but the programmer in the
next apartment is constantly working
charting their growth and talking to
users one day the investor bumps into
the programmer in the mail room and they
strike up a conversation about the
mysterious project
because this programmer has actually
built something there's a lot to talk
about
and the conversation happens quite
naturally that's what a great yc
application should look like
it merely allows the yc partners to get
a glimpse of what's happening at a
startup that is already determined to
succeed
so you've written your answers kept them
all short and to the point
you're making real headway on what
you're building so yc asks you to
interview
what should you do to prepare the answer
is strikingly similar to writing an
application
interview prep still shouldn't be your
number one priority you need to be
building your startup
one of the most impressive things a
startup can do is show
progress between interactions with an
investor
every investor wants to see a line that
goes up into the right but it's really
hard to get a feeling for a trajectory
from a single data point that's why
investors often track companies for
months and sometimes years before
investing
yc has a much shorter time horizon but
it can still be
extremely valuable to show progress
between the time that you apply
and when you interview this doesn't mean
you need to go from idea to massive
company in two weeks
no one is expecting that but just having
written more code developed a new
prototype
or talk to more users can be extremely
meaningful at the early stage
this will benefit your startup
regardless of whether or not you get
into yc
so it's a win-win situation i was just
talking to a very early stage company
that was about to interview with yc
and they were naturally interested in
prepping for the interview and making
sure that they had good answers
but they hadn't actually pushed a
prototype of their product into
production
after prodding a bit i figured out that
they could in fact
launch a very rough but functional
version of their idea before the
interview
and start onboarding users so that's
what i recommended
now i'm not a yc partner and i don't
know if that will be enough for them to
get in
but even if they don't i think they will
be moving faster and learning from these
early experiments
it's important to remember that yc
interviews are only 10 minutes long
so you have to be concise gary tan who's
a former yc partner
outlined three key points that you need
to get across in the interview
first is problem what is it second is
the solution
is it good and are you the ones to do it
third
is how big can it really be if you
succeed
where does this go those are the three
key points you want to get across
and hopefully they should all tie
together into a nice story that anyone
can follow
when we interviewed at yc with my
current company lucy
the pitch was straightforward smoking
kills millions of people
it's a huge problem and we have a
solution in the form of tobacco-free
nicotine products
our team consisted of a former smoker a
phd biochemist
and a programmer and tobacco is a huge
trillion dollar industry globally
if we were successful it would be huge
simple stories like that are extremely
powerful
but it's important not to try and tell a
long story in every one of your answers
since you only have 10 minutes when a
partner asks you a question
don't give a bunch of background
information and explain nitty gritty
details before answering the core
question treat your response like a
newspaper article
and structure the response as an
inverted pyramid
the most important information comes
first then if you have time
you add important details to support
your original point
and then you add background info at the
very end
this allows the partner who asked the
question to cut you off and move on to
the next question if they are satisfied
with your answer
and keeps the interview moving along now
what if you don't get into yc
don't worry at all i know plenty of
founders who applied multiple times
before getting in
and i myself was rejected the first time
i applied
before co-founding soyland i started an
education technology company and applied
to yc
but my application wasn't very good and
i didn't even get an interview
the biggest problem with my application
came down to exactly what jared friedman
outlined
team and idea i hadn't really tested my
idea with any real people who could use
the product that i was building
and my team wasn't really fully formed
yet i had a third co-founder on my
application
but he was on the fence about joining it
seemed like if we got into yc
he would take the leap of faith and join
the company but if we didn't
he wasn't really interested that's a
really bad sign
and i think yc picked up on it everyone
on your team should be fully invested
and willing to work on the problem
regardless of whether or not investors
like the company
tons of companies get rejected by
investors and go on to become massively
successful
determination is everything in startups
so good luck if you apply to yc if you
have any questions about the process
feel free to leave me a comment below or
dm me on twitter
and if you like the video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching